[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'altrove è
qui Ma quando mai ci hanno detto che
l'altrove
qui mai io effettivamente ho sentito ho
sempre sentito una frase nella mia vita
con cui sono cresciuta che mi ha sempre
dimostrato esattamente l'opposto e cioè
che dovevo andare a cercare qualcosa
fuori
qualcosa lontano dalla mia città lontano
dalla mia famiglia lontano da quello che
amavo cioè andare in
barcavela andare a fare le mie
nuotate e non so se è capitato anche a
voi di sentire questa frase qui nella
tua città o nel paese dove sei nato non
c'è posto per te non puoi trovare un
lavoro perché in Italia non c'è futuro e
se vuoi andare ad avere successo Devi
andare
altrove io a questa frase c' ho creduto
Certamente e chiedo a voi siete mai
andati altrove siete andate altrove a
cercare le competenze il vostro
lavoro
non vedo mani alzate strano perché nella
mia città a Genova questa frase se la
sentono dire tutti tutti veramente
E come molti di voi anche i miei amici
molti dei miei amici i miei fratelli e
anche il mio fidanzato sono andati fuori
lui per fortuna dopo 10 anni di
relazione a distanza è appena tornato e
ora andiamo Siamo andati a vivere
assieme ma fra di loro
tra i miei amici c'è qualcuno che pensa
di non poter rimanere qua in Italia
perché crede di non riuscire a trovare
quello che ha trovato fuori ma io oggi
sono qui per dirvi che l'altrove è qui
sono bianca Viola biamonti sono un
artista e sono un'imprenditrice nel mio
lavoro mi occupo di promuovere il
territorio attraverso gli
eventi e di aiutare le persone a tirare
fuori le loro capacità e a realizzare le
loro idee sapete come lo
faccio lo faccio così attraverso la
ceramica la passione per la creta che è
nata Quando avevo 18 anni anzi un po'
prima quando ero al liceo mi ha permesso
di capire che potevo modellare
assolutamente come volevo la mia vita e
allora Appunto Quando ho finito il liceo
e dovevo iscrivermi
all'università Sono andata a capire
cos'è che volevo fare probabilmente
anche voi vi siete sentiti un po' persi
e io ho avuto tre guide nel mio percorso
un professore di scultura uno di
progettazione artistica e uno di diritto
Ero certa e avevo imparato
che L'arte non poteva essere una
professione e quindi ho scelto di fare
diritto mi sono iscritta a
Giurisprudenza e Per dimostrarmi che ero
abbastanza capace a fare le cose
difficili
sono andata anche in Erasmus in Austria
per farla in tedesco giusto per
complicarmi un po' di più ora dovete
immaginare che un ligure è abituato ad
avere il mare al sud e le montagne al
Nord in quel posto a inssbruck mi
trovavo completamente circondata dalle
montagne mi sentivo persa completamente
non sapevo orientarmi ed era anche
difficile per me apprezzare
quell'ambiente così diverso Eppure
volevo stare bene e ho trovato nella
ricerca del territorio il mio modo per
scoprire come stare bene ovunque io
fossi tornata da questa esperienza ero a
Genova mi sono laureata e ho deciso
nuovamente di dovermi buttare e ho
seguito le orme di mio fratello Federico
che da 10 anni in Australia per
realizzare il suo sogno di essere di
diventare architetto ed è riuscito
proprio a farlo là quindi sono andata
sono andata in Australia e soprattutto
una cosa che volevo fare era quello di
andare a percepire cosa si provava a
vivere in un ambiente in uno stato in
cui tutti dicevano che c'erano mille
mila possibilità e devo dirvi la verità
io ho una possibilità ce l'ho avuta ed è
stata è stato per me bellissimo poter
comunicare l'arte aborigine per un museo
ho avuto la possibilità di comunicare
sui social la cultura di un luogo
completamente lontano da me che però mi
ha permesso di comprendere che quello
che volevo fare nella vita si avvicinava
molto a questa esperienza quindi sono
tornata Dopo quasi un anno e a Genova ho
ho deciso di mettere insieme queste due
esperienze di voler promuovere il
territorio o comunque di voler vivere il
territorio e godermelo e la promozione
della Cultura e sono andata a fare un
altro esperienza all'estero e me ne sono
andata tra la Francia a Parigi e Venezia
ora mi dite Bianca eri nella nelle due
città più belle al mondo lì non ti St
Non ti sarà venuto il mugugno e quella
sorta di lamentela che dici sì vabbè no
Eppure anche lì erano bellissime queste
città ve lo giuro lo sapete benissimo ma
quello che volevo fare quello che io
sento di voler fare è di comunicare la
bellezza che è nella mia città che è
nella mia terra e che è questa Liguria
che non è così palese magari non è così
ovvia però io l'ho l'ho la percepisco
il mio desiderio è quella di darla di
farla conoscere a
chiunque così sono tornata allmi altrove
con queste tre cose con questi tre punti
Fermi
e sapete Quand'è che sono
tornata in piena pandemia il giorno
stesso in cui avevamo dichiarato che che
l'Italia sarebbe che era era chiusa
completamente anche lì mi sono sono
tornata nella mia città avevo voglia di
Cioè più che altro vedere cosa fossi
capace a fare e Nonostante questo ho
trovato una città chiusa e la difficoltà
a fare quello che volevo fare promuovere
il territorio e fare degli eventi per
Dedicati ai giovani bene Io in realtà
Grazie all'online sono riuscita a
lavorare e a fare e a lavorare per un
teatro quindi abbiamo progettato tutti
degli eventi che sarebbero poi
realizzati una volta eh una volta in
buona speranza avevamo già già una buona
speranza che
eh che saremmo riusciti a realizzare
questi eventi in concreto appena sarebbe
finita la
situazione però nel momento in cui mi
sentivo persa sono andata un po'
sgattaiolato un po' di nascosto senza
farmi vedere troppo da nessuno nella mia
stanzetta in cui Avo lasciato 80 kg di
Creta me l'ero regalata per la laurea
poi l'avevo abbandonata lì perché sapevo
che appena toccavo questo materiale io
perdevo completamente la testa e potevo
andare potevo il tempo si dilatava e per
me non sarei non sarei riuscita a fare
altro solo dedicandomi alla terra e
allora ho capito piano piano che mi
stavo stavo realizzando attorno a me
tutte le cose che volevo vedere e
conoscere della Liguria Quindi mi sono
messa a fare delle sculture delle balene
perché sarei voluta andare a scoprire il
mare sono mi sono messa a disegnare i
piatti con la costa ligure e mi sono
accorta presto che quello che mi
interessa della Creta non era tanto il
l'oggetto in sé ma piano piano la creta
mi stava faccendo vedere qual era la mia
strada mi stava facendo mi stava
insegnando che io potevo realizzare e
modificare la mia strada quando volevo
senza sentirmi impantanata e obbligata a
fare un percorso
unico vedete quando una persona si
entusiasma e ha gli occhi che brillano
sarà successo anche a voi V arrivano un
sacco di persone attorno a te che magari
anche per paura di vederti che potresti
andare ovunque magari perderti cercano
di confinar o comunque prendere il tuo
entusiasmo e farti vedere tutte le parti
problematiche difficili e sicuramente
queste persone qua ad averle accanto e
vicino è difficile fan soffrire Magari
ti fanno proprio e già magari non sei
proprio sicuro di quello che vuoi andare
a fare fare lo senti o senti una
motivazione grande dentro di te però
alla fine dici ma farò veramente bene Mi
starò buttando queste persone qua in
realtà servono per come un controllore
per vedere se effettivamente abbiamo
questa motivazione perché non vi
preoccupate che se voi sentite nel
profondo una motivazione così alta di
andare a vedere cosa siete capaci a fare
e vi mettete con costanza a seguirlo
viene da sé che passo dopo passo
riuscirete a realizzare la strada che
volete sapete perché il mio desiderio è
quello di far provare la terra a
chiunque anzi vi chiedo a voi alzi la
mano se qualcuno fra di voi ha mai
provato questo a modellare questo
materiale OK pochini Vabbè qualcuno lì
non vi vedo 2e tre È pochissimo Beh a me
questo materiale qua piace perché all
alla fine m ha fatto capire che e mi ha
fatto capire a me ma anche ai miei
corsisti durante i miei corsi di di
ceramica che puoi realizzare veramente
quello che vuoi Cioè hai qualunque idea
e non è anche se è un'idea nuova che ne
che nessuno ha mai fatto anch'io ogni
tanto viene qualcuno che mi dice voglio
fare sta cosa qua io li guardo Però il
bello è che ti permette di avere una
forma mentale per riuscire a trasformare
tutto ciò che semplicemente con le mani
con l'ascolto di di noi stessi ci
permette di trasformare tutto questo
materiale in qualunque tipo di cosa e
questo per me mi affascina molto e
quello che ho scoperto che mi ha
insegnato questo la creta è stata
proprio di nel momento in cui che nel
momento in cui ti dedichi del tempo e
uno spazio per riconnetterti con quello
che sei tu con quello che senti quello
che fai veramente Cioè quello che voglio
dire è che nel momento in cui hai questo
materiale nelle mani tu vai
a ad avere molta più sensibilità nei
confronti di quello che vivi sviluppi
tantissimo il senso del tatto e la tua
sensibilità proprio si alza e quindi
riesci a capire subito Qual è il tuo
intuito Dov'è che ti porta Io in quel
periodo lì nonostante sentissi vi dico
la verità un un entusiasmo per quello
che facevo con la creta io avevo
paurissima di buttarmi e di di fare una
un percorso diverso rispetto a quanto
avevo studiato avevo investito
tantissimo anche la mia famiglia mi
aveva sostenuto Cioè per me avevo fatto
una fatica che non potete immaginare ad
arrivare a fare tutto questo percorso e
il pensiero che per una passione che
magari poteva essere anche finire dopo 2
minuti o un mese cambiare completamente
prospettiva In più ho provato anche a
lavorare per Eh il pubblico ho lavorato
facevo eventi culturali facevo
promozione del territorio era proprio
dal punto di vista della società in un
luogo o comunque in un posto di lavoro
che dicevano V Beh Brava fai anche delle
cose bello però sapete cosa
succedeva io lì dentro in quei posti
Sentivo di non riuscire a dare un
contributo di alcun tipo nonostante cioè
ero lì andavo lì ero presente ma mi
dicevano Bianca m bellissima le tuo idea
Però abbiam sempre fatto così Quindi
cambia la data Mettila quella di
quest'anno e manda le mail io questa
cosa qua non non riuscivo a farla Cioè
non S mi sentivo veramente ingabbiata e
per me è stato un un ritornare una una
via Unica quella che potevo fare quella
che mi rimaneva cioè di ringraziare
tutti e dire io apro qualcosa di mio non
so come andrà non so ancora come andrà
Però io apro buon vento buon vento è il
mio laboratorio di promozione del il
territorio che è a Genova in centro
storico e se vi capitasse mai di venire
a trovarmi probabilmente vi vi
stuzzicherà o comunque vi una delle cose
che noterete di più sono tutte questi
cetacei che li ho messi ovunque tra i
disegni nelle sculture sono ho fatto
delle balene che attraversano i muri e
questo animale qua vi dico la verità mi
ha ispirato da S seme soprattutto nel
momento in cui Ne ho visto uno ho visto
un un capodolio e mi aveva stupito per
due motivi per il suo comportamento
Innanzitutto
è un animale che per poter vivere e
poter navigare fare la sua strada ha
bisogno di andare in quello che è il suo
altrove cioè andare semplicemente a
prendere una grande boccata d'aria e poi
cosa fa si immerge nella
profondità e
poi
l'altro aspetto è che non te lo aspetti
che ci sia un animale così grande in
mezzo al mare noi in Liguria vediamo
questa distesa blu meravigliosa che a
qualcuno fa paura qualcuno invece no
però la cosa che colpisce e che a me ha
colpito È che il momento in cui ero in
barcavela e ho trovato questo animale
che ho visto questa coda ho detto ma io
ho sempre fatto questa navigazione
perché facevo facevo la volontà per una
regata di ma io ho fatta 6 anni eppure
non ho mai visto nessun tipo di animale
così grande il fatto che si fosse
palesato a me per me è stato un simbolo
di Bianca svegliati vivi qua fai
qualcosa qua e goditi la bellezza di
questo momento non c'è non si può andare
ad aspettare delle le occasioni perfette
perché c'è bisogno di crearle c'è
bisogno non c'è un posto perfetto per
noi è Siamo noi che possiamo creare il
posto perfetto per inserirci e trovare
il modo e la
strada più giusta per noi ed è per
questo che oggi vi ho raccontato che
l'altrove è qui
E il mio
desiderio è proprio quello di augurarvi
di trovare il vostro altrove ovunque voi
siate o comunque trovare la strada la
vostra strada ovunque sia per voi dove
voi state bene e questo piccola
balenottera anzi in realtà è un
capodoglio ve lo voglio regalare
Zac che sia per come ricordo come
ispirazione per poter trovare la vostra
strada dentro di voi vi
[Applauso]
ringrazio
n